-Here at "The Tonight Show,"
we love songs.
And we especially love songs
written by our audience members
in under an hour.
It's time for "Battle of
the Instant Songwriters."
Here we go.
-♪ Something sung,
and singing the song ♪
♪ And I'm writing the song
about another song ♪
-Welcome to "Battle of
the Instant Songwriters."
Before the show,
we went through our audience
and picked out two people
who said they were musicians.
[ Laughter ]
We gave them each
a made-up song title
and gave them an hour
to write an original song
based on that title.
Here's a shot of them practicing
backstage a minute ago.
Oh, they're both
playing the piano.
I thought they were
typing out their words.
Let's see
what they came up with.
Let's meet them right now.
Come on over, guys.
Hey, welcome to the show.
Hi.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We doing the elbows?
Is that what we're doing?
Hi.
-Yeah.
-Perfect. Welcome.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for doing this.
I know you didn't know
you were gonna be on the show,
but here you are, on the show.
Let's start with
contestant number one.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-I'm Kimberly Denaro.
I'm from Massachusetts.
-Yeah! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kimberly, welcome to the show.
-Thanks.
-What was the title of the song
that you were given?
-"I'm Scared of my Roomba."
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
That sounds like a hit.
What instrument
will you be playing?
-The piano.
-All right, very nice.
Why don't you head over there
and get yourself ready to go.
And we'll get to hear...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Get ready to go.
What was the name again?
"I'm Scared of my Roomba"?
Yeah, that's pretty funny.
All right, ladies and gentlemen,
here to perform
the world premiere
of the soon-to-be classic
"I'm Scared of my Roomba,"
it's Kim Denaro!
[ Cheer and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ In the middle of the night,
I saw it gliding like a ghost ♪
♪ A squeaky shadow
crashing into the corner ♪
♪ Devouring every crumb
in its path ♪
♪ I told myself
"Oh, don't worry about that ♪
♪ It's probably just a rat ♪
♪ But worse,
it was the Roomba ♪
No!
♪ I'm scared of my Roomba ♪
♪ I live with a robot ♪
♪ That memorized
the layout of my room ♪
♪ Because I was too
lazy to vacuum ♪
♪ I took the battery out,
but it's possessed ♪
♪ A hockey puck of suction ♪
♪ Continuing to clean
while plotting my abduction ♪
♪ It's only a matter of time
before the machines take over ♪
♪ And I can't speak the language
of vroom vroom ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ But the Roomba of doomba
with it's stomach full of dust ♪
♪ Is a robot that
I'll never trust ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Kim Denaro.
Come over.
Kim Denaro!
[ Applause ]
You wrote a legit song.
Very funny.
Thank you, Kim.
All right, let's meet
contestant number two.
What is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name's Ryder Chasin,
and I'm from Connecticut.
-Yeah, Ryder Chasin
from Connecticut.
Thank you for being here, Ryder.
Ryder, tell everyone
what your song title was.
-Yeah, they gave me "I Bought
an Off-Brand Rapid Test."
[ Laughter ]
-I feel like I've heard
that song before.
This is amazing.
You will be playing piano,
as well?
-The electric organ
on the keyboard.
-Oh, I'm so sorry.
Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Thanks for correcting me.
I appreciate it.
-Please, yeah.
-Please, go get ready
to do your --
-Oh, thank you.
-Go by your electric organ.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's so funny.
Ladies and gentlemen, get ready
for the world premiere of
"I Bought
an Off-Brand Rapid Test,"
done on the electric organ,
by Ryder Chasin.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Wanted to go Upstate
so I had to validate ♪
♪ That I didn't have the COV ♪
♪ CVS was out of stock ♪
♪ So I traveled down the block ♪
♪ And into the Dollar store
I dove ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ I should've known
when they sold it ♪
♪ Next to staples
and loose screws ♪
♪ I should've known
when the nasal swab said ♪
♪ Warning, slightly used ♪
♪ I should've known
'cause the brand was something ♪
♪ I had never seen ♪
♪ And right on the package,
it said COVID-17 ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Got no clue
if I got the 'rona ♪
♪ Guess I'm staying
home alone...a ♪
♪ 'Cause I bought
an off-brand rapid test ♪
♪ 'Cause I brought an
unplanned, legally banned ♪
♪ Off-brand rapid test ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
Give it up for Ryder Chasin!
Thank you very much, Ryder.
Now it is time to see who won.
We're gonna let our great
audience decide the winner.
Was it Kim Denaro?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Or was it Ryder Chasin?
[ Loud cheers and applause ]
It looks like the winner
is Ryder Chasin!
Congratulations, Ryder!
♪♪
Ryder, Congratulations.
You will be going home
with $1,000 -- yeah --
and a "Tonight Show" notebook
for writing more songs.
There you go.
Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-No, no one goes home
empty-handed.
You will also be getting
a notebook with $1,000.
Kim, you write more songs.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And thank you for doing that.
I appreciate it.
Give it up for our two
instant songwriters!
Thank you for doing that.
That was amazing!